do you know your next move or do you
even think like that because I think
about how you got started David Foster
says I know this great singer you said
in for Andrea Bocelli and the rest is
history and there you are you know I
think that diving head first into
something as challenging and rewarding
as as this
um it it you know it empties your tank
in some ways you got to keep finding
ways to refill every night but then it
also really fills your creative tank to
think about other things and so while I
might have a loose idea of what I want
to do next the kind of album I want to
make or whatever else
um I kind of let the chills guide me
this this was something chills this was
a big risk and you know something
something about this said to me you know
whatever happens this is something I'm
going to be really really passionate
about and whenever I've done something
for that reason it's always worked out